[Música]
eu trabalho nestas coisas é difícil pois
eles são pilotos também vou falar uma
coisa se tiver dúvidas t1 ou não tinham
as obras e saber mais ou menos né mas
falando besteira eu trabalhei a parte
fraca produção seja o pensamento de que
seus pesares plano no vasco pois podem
não dar conta disso ele não fala num
ponto estão na pesquisa que possui 75 cm
falou menino e tudo que você é
completamente infundada
se vocês considerarem que há uns
crianças do mundo o the new e que
maneira isso é normal é 8 inteira e
ninguém vai ter problemas quando ele
está pronto pra todos nós temos nossos
vinhos país em inglês é bastante nossos
inglês de 98 ocupam 16 em toda a causa é
em 98 mil fiéis a seu toque sensível
mérito se tornem oficiais e diria que
nós temos é que nem todos sejam iguais
diferentes
aí quando essas pessoas geralmente
consegue chegar a um local no qual é a
linguagem que aprender fotos em conjunto
este desafio porque eu vim aqui te falar
que não estou mais gostoso
[Música]
agora notório é essa mas não posso ir lá
e quando essa média campeonato da truck
ele ficará em férias com grande
dificuldade
isso pode explicar por que isso acontece
nós fazemos é criar um vácuo dos
fragmentos do tecido a light técnicos
para cuidar do setor
êêê equipa e nós somos o centro foi esse
país quer entender que estaria têm sido
as investigações não é só fazemos cenas
com os músicos senhores que quer saber o
que é isso que estamos a trabalhar mesmo
com um onze está sempre atrás de novos
estudantes está sendo que a maioria
deles a coisa piora tudo isso o
microfone não dá tempo não vai ver uma
coisa com letterman não é a linguagem
escrita
você não ganhar mesmo jucá não vejo
lógica saber senhora aqui alguém que não
saiba quem é a senhora pronto a história
nós aprendemos que esse é o primeiro
edital
ok eu dou coisas aos meus alunos energia
agora nas minhas aulas do coisas que
eram equipe e talvez por ser dizer
lembra daquela história que fosse ricas
não fui eu foi o usuário
fui aprender por exemplo é bom e ovelha
só nessa minha filha ele disse não não
há nomes da velha bota essa história tá
e bolacha estável em turim dos golfinhos
eu tô na agenda staff e ninguém está a
ver outra coisa são muito mal
intencionado estamos o irmão filho
a expectativa das pessoas às ruas
somente sobre o confisco de calor fim
o feriado não anunciou quem está na
frente é pequena e por isso a polícia
está aí o nosso de tomar com embriões
que são as empresas mais próximas alta e
isso foi plantar muda para erguer juntos
só não posso fazer nada eu pessoalmente
também não posso mesmo fazer nada
o pequenino vantagem da sua história uma
caixa perto não sou profeta estava vai
aproveitar isso nós vamos aproveitar
essa lei anterior
olhou para cima essa coisa não tá mesmo
a maior conseguida pelo único agente
condição de estar produzindo uma
substância branca do corpo e é não dá um
tempo sócios e ninguém falasse é quando
faz apresentações inclusive nessa doença
renal e até estranharam não só a própria
meta
se ele está nisto e esta coisa da mesma
entidade é que o núcleo dos sábados
nós dissemos de forma manual de
instruções para eleger o prefeito murilo
e depois que era capitão da origem e
proteínas fato enquanto é o músico é
todas as coisas
o material faz coisas nossa vida tudo é
simples agora não haja esforço em março
é como
escolhi eu não posso são bons ou maus
por isso é muito feio isso é uma praga
na posição caminho encontrou escolhidos
manter o ecossistema foi mal vista é
muito bonita
alguns gestos promove nós chega nada
assim
ajuda também passam cá e as sugestões
que são muitas ações que alterações
isso coloca uma frase a frase percebido
a sala funciona é estrondosa e toda acha
que estou biologia e as pescarias
passarão a nossa história é um dia muito
inspirado nela porque o que ela trouxe
mandetta mostrar uma só letra só tomou
esta frase a frase não seria
completamente enfrenta assim novas são
assim passa a ser lançado
está anunciada vai embora as duas tenham
de ser fã malária
o curioso é que as pessoas começam a
pensar só estudamos uma frase uma bola
assim é
vai ser tudo assim para todas as doenças
e não é é só praia
muito poucas pessoas vão ter essas metas
o outro vai variar irá manter as outras
não é tudo jeff colas surgir as
instituições todo o dna ea resposta é
por menos
já que em nada dignifica a taxa de
investigação fácil seria a tecnologia é
um exemplo de biotecnologia
completamente fora a colegas meus fãs
querem unificar a andritz fazem filhos
por fazer teresina com duas canecas
ainda é proteína do leite foi fazendo
queijo ganhe sempre mais
estamos fazendo ao menos no caixa ou não
reagiu mas é por vizinhos que essa é a
segunda com muita teoria e pouca prática
como é que as coisas funcionaram nosso
estudo ela não sofreu qualquer coisa
chamada em nossa para a implantação dos
embriões tira sua selva vezes isso estão
todas cobertas e só se transferem os
embriões saiu dessa eventualmente por
exemplo vez acompanhou judeu ortodoxo
completamente torto mais fácil nada a
ver comigo há uma pessoa que trabalha
comigo dos finados é tentar terminar só
transferir níveis que não podemos ao
elche que não é pedro poças pensar no
final eu não tenho que selecionar que
não modifica
isso é o que o instituto está agora a
conduzir uma nova técnica não envolve
três pancadas não é mais aquele aspecto
as cores de deus cruz muito bem com
muita precisão e é isso está com dúvidas
na área de edificações dele é
espetacular porque nunca se sabe o dia
que acontece até sexta quando acontece
porque temos exatamente quando ele está
feliz com isso só que os muito maus do
presídio
eu sou um grande artista de um metro e
oitenta e três de bronze gostou da pedra
é mais fácil fazer isto também é hora
está sendo feito agora é a primeira vez
que foi produzida uma mutação em branco
mas até agora não era que o tempo não é
errado pensar sobre isso e água funciona
[Música]
eu não posso falar a verdade eu não
posso fazê lá embaixo com isso o total
de mortes não é só você
as ligações não são iguais não existirá
que se chegasse a esse nível de gastos
acham sobre isso
em agosto de 2007 pra não vou ser mais
um pouco isto fizeram sondagens hoje nos
estados unidos é que as pessoas pensam
poder isto é procurar coisas em vídeos
anúncio por a coisa sem vida não tinha a
sua cedência bolsa gigante aumentar as
capacidades aéreas e melhorar meu lado
não só essas pessoas lá atrás da tensão
do dia irá procurar ainda vá que não vá
melhorar e já não sinto muito gostava
que significa tirar você pega não
transmitir aos filhos parece as duas
foram própria vida se não há prova
nenhuma mais problemas suas operações na
china
outra coisa que eu acho que se utilizar
é que mais de 20 pessoas acham que a
população deve ser ouvida
curiosamente as pessoas com
conhecimentos na área da ciência da nasa
que se eles são gastos correntes e fazem
isso não tem clube que um deixou de
dizer só treinar que é mais -
condicionando a partir do zero é baixa
atinge ozunu interessado japão causadas
por essas três grandes terra
a associação a cambada não desconfiaria
os mesmos que querem ser vistos fala o
professor nilson imagem
por isso é porque eu sei que essas
coisas se não for eu a participar da
principal outra coisa que não concorda
comigo
vamos dizer que em casa não disse nada
não fui história já que estabeleça
ambientais em prova com os pés muito são
todos afirmar a coisa não fez um bom
trabalho coisa pro nosso usuário decidir
esta missão também não é só fazer
ciência para o doctor's no fim não sabe
ao certo quando é pra isso que eu estou
pensando apenas tentava uma manobra de
origem
nós tentamos fazer também um trabalho de
explicar às pessoas porque estamos a
fazer sempre quando estamos a ser outra
senão a de serviços convênios como
deputado ele foi desenhado para trazer
bandas ready to rock da banda desenhada
como foi lidar com ele
e um dia - é o nosso fazer mas gostava
de banda desenhada centenas dessas
coisas assim
ah e não vi os meus colegas e diga-nos
achava que estava perto do rio vão
tomando nada não sabia que era
socialista pessoa tenha sido isso não
significa fazer mais nada
se a conclusão quando era mais por aqui
há um tempo que pega uma pessoa se você
não é uma pessoa consultar essas coisas
não me machuquei na lei pelé quem vocês
podem ser coisas ou santana explicado a
semana mas sentiu se revela é que nossas
coisinhas aqui a pena só explicar as
suas metas coisas funcionam e que
precisava ser tão belas quanto a do
impacto que é que estava com trabalho
com essas pessoas aprenderam com isso
tornar porque o cara que fala bonito
as pessoas que tiveram alguma coisa que
eles não precisam provar o contrário não
acontece no nosso evento
esse é o ponto que nós temos pelo
senador
eu não faço assim o trabalho só essa
nota todo e mais ele só alguns dias
algumas pessoas colocam eu espero que
faleceu sábado
hoje essa também deve falar da banda a
música só uma
então essa sua espera que estejam a
trabalhar e falta um minuto e quarenta e
levar o mesmo vai treinar a memória quer
na brigada qualquer dúvida coisas deixam
iluminado para não dizer nada
[Aplausos]